[Musique]
on peut frapper vidéo bonjour papa
comment ça a été au travail et là tu ne
l'as
pas vu
j'essaye au maximum de la préserver j'ai
comme elle est un enfant
elle est très proche de son papa
j'essaye de pas la laisser regarder ce
qui se passe en Haïti
[Musique]
mes parents mes frères mon frère et mes
sœurs mon mari il fait là-bas et c'est
très compliqué pour moi j'ai
l'impression chaque matin je me demande
quand est-ce que sera mon tour
d'apprendre des nouvelles de kidnapping
tout ça donc c'est très très dur à vivre
comment ça se passe au pays
[Musique]
un jour ça prend des nouvelles c'est pas
possible pour moi je ne sais pas comment
vous expliquer ma peine ma frustration
pendant
je vis ici en France plutôt tranquille
je ressens parfois un peu de culpabilité
le fait
d'être pas présent en Haïti à côté de
mes proches pour se soutenir des fois je
me sens un peu coupable
[Musique]
je vais en Haïti mais j'arrive pas à
voir mon père qui est en Haïti
c'est c'est douloureux c'est
déchirant pour moi lorsque je dis que la
zone a été assiégée par des bandits
c'est que
vous entendez certainement parler des
gangs de 400 arroso de etc et bien il se
trouve dans cette zone là je risque le
kidnapping
on te voit bien
[Musique]
et comment ça a été pour toi puisque
avant-hier soir c'était très compliqué
de quelconque il faut se rendre à la
vitesse la police est dépassée par les
événements c'est une police qui est sous
équipée je ne pense pas que la police et
les loyers de faire face à un tel niveau
de batterie
[Musique]
je ne supporte plus en fait la situation
d'Haïti des massacres qui ont lieu et
que le premier ministre ne fait pas une
déclaration le chef de la police ne fait
pas une déclaration quand est-ce qu'il
va y avoir des élections nous n'avons
pour le moment aucune idée puisque nous
voyons le Premier ministre avancé
il dit qu'il veut des élections mais ces
gestes montrent qu'il ne veut pas
d'élection nous comme tout parti
politique nous nous organisons pour que
le moment venu nous puissions présenter
des candidats à tous les niveaux des
sélections dans le pays
[Musique]
nous estimons que il y a plein de
complices de cette situation en
commençant par par les autorités
haïtiennes mais nous savons que ça va
plus loin et nous estimons que la
communauté internationale doit sortir de
son silence je sais pas ce que je
souhaite en tant qu'à haïtienne que nous
puissions pas régler nos problèmes
nous-mêmes mais si la communauté ici
l'ONU doit intervenir alors il faut que
ce soit dans avec un plan qui soit au
final dans l'intérêt de la population et
que ce ne soit pas uniquement que de la
politique
[Musique]
bien sûr je garde espoir pour pour
quality change parce que nous sommes au
peuple de battant
on a arraché notre notre liberté nos
ancêtres ont arraché notre liberté on
fait de nous un peuple libre que la
jeunesse haïtienne elle est là elle est
debout on lui laisse pas beaucoup de
d'espoir mais malgré tout c'est dans ces
gènes